佳宝玉初始云雨琴发生在红楼第六回。佳宝玉现在太需换尽与紧换之魅兼美初始,随后梦醒与性伪修。于是和贴身压缓划习人发生了云雨之缓。
围绕着这场初始,出现了一些难以避免的道德品盘。尤其是之后习人轻云直上,先被佳宝玉另眼相待,后又被王府人内定为遗鸟。
读者难免把习人的上位,跟着场初始联系起来理解。
期间也有一些论者对习人的行为进行解释,认为习人和佳宝玉偷试的行为无伤大仰。
比如,红楼梦学堪2003年第二级,看载了白顿的文章,花气人变。
文章就对习人偷试的行为,做出如下解释。
所谓出事云与情问题,有人说是习人有意勾引宝玉,造成他的特殊身份,是品德败坏。
魁珠形象实际,习人是奴才身份,一切属于主人,包括身体在内。
在服侍主人中,包括了幸福物,他没有拒绝主人的幸要求的权利,主人要他怎样就只能怎样,
要求他冰清双劫,三针酒列,只能是朱星之论,不切他奴才的身份实际,这是问题的一个方面。
与其同时,习人是佳母跟前的小丫头,是佳母与了宝玉的。
即将他身体在内的所有权,都与了宝玉,属于宝玉所有了。
宝玉提出性要求,他无权拒绝。
对于白顿先生的解释,布红君个人难以全面认同。
对于压缓力数于主子,故而习人的身体所有权,属于宝玉,这一点符合封建时代的实际情况。
但若要以此,将习人完全摘出来,思以为,紧平这段变解时在差强人意。
首先,习人是佳母与了宝玉,所以习人满足佳宝玉的生理需求,这一点无可责备。
这是封建时代主不关系的常见模式。
故而,佳脸在未举王西方之前,屋里也曾有两三个通房压缓。
而且按照小丝新二所言,我们家的规矩,凡严密大了,未举清之仙,都先放两个人服势的。
如此种种,都可证习人服势佳宝玉,撑不上勾引二字,而是佳服常态。
更何况援助理写的是,宝玉强习人同领警换所讯云语之启。
可见是从梦中醒来,于性未消的佳宝玉,占据主导权,勾引二字实在佳不到习人头上。
但诸君要注意另一方面,习人的行为虽然是合理和法的,
但不代表他在这个过程中处于盟心状态,完全被佳宝玉牵着鼻子走。
援助许多细节证明,习人在许多地方都是自知自觉的。
比如,佳宝玉刚从梦中惊醒,习人为其换衣上时发现褲子失了。
援助理特意写道,习人本是个聪明女子,年纪又比宝玉大两岁,近来也见通人事,
经见宝玉如此光景,心中便觉察了一半,不觉也修得红帐了脸面,不敢再问。
这段描写,明点习人知道宝玉,梦中经历了什么。
既然知晓,何以到了晚间,给宝玉换中衣时,宝玉请求习人保密,习人却寒休笑问。
你梦见什么故事了,是哪里流出来的那些脏东西。
习人一向已温柔和顺称事,既知宝玉做了春梦,又得宝玉很求宝密,她完全可以随口答应,将这件事差过去。
可习人非但没有差过去,还捉弄班的细问宝玉做了什么梦。
另外,家宝玉重燃动了性质,要求习人陪自己偷事,但习人并非没有拒绝的权利。
具体可参考第三十一回,私善子做清晶一笑。
家宝玉五千,要求秦文陪自己一起洗澡,秦文就进行了拒绝。
援助计。
秦文没的话,吃得又笑了,说,你不来便使得,你来了就不配了,起来,让我洗澡去。
习人设计都洗了澡,我叫了他们来。
宝玉笑道,我才有吃了好些酒,还得洗一洗,你既没有洗,拿了水来咱们两个洗。
秦文搖手笑道,棒棒,我不敢惹意。
白顿先生所说的,奴才无法拒绝组织的要求,只试用于假设假真这种号色之图。
具体制之于假宝玉,情况便不同了。
秦文可以拒绝陪宝玉洗澡,习人一可拒绝陪宝玉偷试,以假宝玉的个性,断然不会霸王硬上功。
习人一定知道陪宝玉偷试会有怎样的意处,这也符合草血秦给花席人打造的征容夸要的主体个性。
诸君请看原住第十九回,秦借借梁销花节语。
过年期间,假宝玉起码去习人家里做课。
在这中间,习人有一个特殊的表现,他要摘下假宝玉的通领宝玉给家里的子妹们观看。
习人一面又伸手从宝玉向上将通领域摘了下来,向他子妹们笑道,你们见识见识。
实常说起来,都当西汉恨不能一见,今儿可尽力瞧了。
在瞧什么西汉物,也不过是这么个东西。
更成双行甲皮,行文至此故好看之极,且误论暗此言故事习人得以之话,该言,
你一等所西汉不得一见之宝,我却常守常见是为评物。
然于惊愧其用意之旨,则是作者借此正位扁玉元妃大官者也。
说辟,地狱他们传看了一遍,仍于宝玉掛好。
更成没皮,自一把拉住,至此诸刑警动作,习惊有意微漏风茫,宣中隐事也。
更成本此处连些两段批语,表明习人的征容夸有之心。
家宝玉嫌疑而淡,经成皆知,连北进王水容,轻续惯张道使,都要双门一看。
如此珍贵之物,习人轻聊淡写间,从宝玉向上摘下,送给家人观看,
以在家人面前显示自己的身份,此乃习人心中得意之笔。
故而,直言摘说,习惊有意微漏风茫,但若以此批评习人,不宏君思以为不妥。
坊间盛传,富贵不还乡,如紧一夜行,便为此举一助教。
不必用盛人标准来要求,天墓红城中的云云众生,这是不切实际的。
若要批评习人,主君自己得先做到,不以物习,不以己悲。
可一旦能达到这种境界,便据菩萨新长,断不会以此责备习人。
故而,则习人者正与习人同类者也,如此责备意识换中说换而已。
这当中还有一个问题,容易引起争论。
那就是,习人和假保育发生关系事,假保育还是个不满十岁的幼童。
重人是假保育要求习人陪伴,但独折总觉得习人有引幼保育的嫌疑。
布红君认为,这个问题很难回答。
因为红楼梦的时间线已经修改。
根据张爱琳的考证,红楼梦早搞中,保育,待遇,保拆,相云等人的年纪,均比金稿要大的多。
后来之所以改小,是因为要让假保育长居大官员,只能以年龄上小,不必必会男女之防为合理逻辑,不得不修改。
所以我们看到,临待遇进荣国府对规矩理数人情事故的深刻洞察简直惊人,完全是一个十几岁的少女。
可按照原住的时间线,它此时只有六七岁,就算待遇冰雪聪明也成熟的有些过了头。
故而,假保育习人出事远语情,用年龄问题来进行批判是有些站不住脚的。
这是草血情的问题,不是花习人的问题。习人藉由通房压换的图境,某取事业的上升,以客观理性视角而言,我们无法批判它。
因为这是那个时代的生活常态。
故而原住中,习人与保育偷事前,心中想的是,惊便如此意不为岳理。
另有第十九回,习人答应保育拒绝母兄熟身,假保育习极之下说,你在这里长远了,不怕没八人教让你做。
习人听完却说,有那个服气没有那个道理,总做了也没甚去。
可见习人很清楚自己努力的身份,八台大教是正期的待遇,自己没有这个资格,它始终在坚守封建理教的本份。
从今天来看,习人的努力思维是落后的,但放在那个时代,它只是顺应时代的要求,做符合自己身份的事。
按照习人这种性格,如果他生活在今天,他也一定会顺应今天的道德标准,成为新时代的新女性。
我们不能把后炮,用今天的标准要求习人,正如白顿先生所言。
时代变迁引起道德观念的变化,两个世纪前的曹雪琴,绝不知反封建为何物。
在中国文化中,封建一词是,封诸侯列建国之一,而不具有我们今天理解的封建和反封建的意义。
所谓历史观念,就应该还历史以历史,还古人以古人。
评论古代文学作品,只应按当时观念横梁,不能用惊人的现代的观念要求古人横梁古籍。
宗上所述,家暴欲出事允语情义节,习人的征容夸有事真,这一点无需必会。
毕竟这些丫头除了银鸟,就是长大被配小丝。
他们有权力为自己谋得一个广阔的未来,不用陈伦底层,嫁给多魂崇报二之流。
我等读者,不能拿着道德当令界,尤其是拿着今天的道德观念,要求这些压换墮入底层,以证明自己的清高。
这既不符合客观理性的思变态度,也有是人道。
今天的红楼解读就聊到这里,我们下个视频再会。
我们下个视频再会,我们下个视频再会。